WOOOOOOOOOOAAH
wOOOOh
sMaSh LiKE
[original content intro]
Dab dab dab dab
What's up my bros!
(no squad fam?) 5
It is time for another
LIIIIIITT
horror game
That's right you guys love horror games
I know that you like it so --
[cringe intensifies]
SO IF YOU LIKE IT
mAkE sUre To SMASH
dAt LiKe bUTtON
RIGHt NOW
If we destroy it
literally i'm talking about game breaking
destroying the youtube glitch bug
I'm literally saying if we can break
the youtube algorithm
That's right everybody
There will be another part two if that happens
This video is called
Try Not To Fall Asleep Challenge
I was trying to watch the Jack
play this but I just fell asleep
so I figured why don't I just play it myself
I'MJUSTKIDDING
Oh GREAT is another five
nights at freddy's clone
fAnTAsTIc
okay, why not
alright, let's remain positive sw-
- oH nO
- [in game] Well, nice to meet you Mr. Heron
closes a bee as a medical assistant robot
my core function is to give guidance to my patients and provide a supportive presence okay an emergency such as a
mental breakdown
okay, okay then mutant robot
good good tuck
okay, so i'm just gonna chill you know we're just gonna fall asleep together this is now an asmr video
hey
let's fall asleep this is the sound of my beard yeah
Whoa what was that oh god i'm getting super stressed what's happening i can't keep the light on for too long
okay
This is fine i'm really good at micromanagement so this is totally fine hello why is falling asleep so stressful
Looks like you got a high hallucinations too hard it's time
i
don't mind sleeping with someone stares at me
makes it's actually comforting for me
makes me feel good makes me feel nice
That's normal that's just our local alcoholic a local drunkard oh?
that's
Who looks like you got a big hallucination there
next time you should hide in the blanket before that happens how do you know what i'm hallucinating
That's normal that's normal i don't have any problem with any of this oh?
dude that's really bad
All right surely i'm falling asleep now yeah no but i'm asleep
just, thank you thank you oh wait what
All right so now i am someone else oh
exit the main lab building and locate the power generator
man i am tall dude wow this is kind of creepy
to study on plant endurance
that's plenty of work for me
wow, game of the year
everyone
it's like i'm taking
ginormous steps
it's a microscope thank you game
jesus
Whoa i got a little spooked down at or nothing i'm not smelling exit perfect let's just go to the exit
Hello hello
fine what
Are their names perfect if yours is oh damn it alright let's find the fuses bros
easy good thing i never a look at that random fuse oh
please
i'm good
i'm good i'd rather accept my fate i
said i changed my mind sheesh are you spooked out yet i
am literally dying
it's a good thing i never get scared while playing games unlike you you
little cry-baby
It says my stress went up a little bit and i kinda have to agree to be honest oh fair one heck yeah
awesome pick it
met my dude like i don't fine fine
so at one time i had too much sugar i
got all crazy i just owe
success heck yeah guys smash that like button right now if you thought that was the success come on
Have you ever liked or single one of my videos well today is the day
other people watch buddha but do you think they're inside the building i
wonder maybe i should check real quick
Hello, oh!
there are okay oh gosh gosh i forgot oh my gosh
to much sugar
i'm going in circle our name
suck, shush smash that like fun right now guys can we smash it
Hello hello fuse fuse give me the fuse
Fuse give me a fuse come out give me refuse give me the fuse come on man?
I said
taste vista they were a fan
smash like come on guys
man it feels great not, to be one of those creaky youtubers anymore
Like i rent i ran here like a million times already
like dog you can't keep doing that
Come on where is it i don't have all day?
they've all fee in it who just put random fuses everywhere
everywhere how about you had stored them in the storage and not just sprinkle them over like glitter yeah my few spot
yeah, my first fine it has to be inside i
looked everywhere outside it
may be one of the top floors oh can it can it can they can they can they can they can they can
come in
oh, joe joe joe joe this is bad this is really bad guys guys i don't have great feelings about
Did it's very not good my in it hey you know i hate okay okay hey wait does?
your deviant
we're fine take that pole in
your
teeth they're poor and feet that
oh
that was stressful thank god i see the parts my god did you pick what do you think cage with the sea
The futures just scrambled all over the place i had to go find them and put them back
yeah it was weird kate i bet you're the one that did it your quad
yellow weasel i'll wait for you at the entrance lobby in the lamp okay
kate kate
All right i think it's over here hello whoa oh, no not kate ain't that far what about kate
kate
kate oh you're right kate are you sleeping right now honestly kate really disappointed in you i
just fixed all i
fixed all of the generators kate kate kate i
fixed all of the generator and here you are
just sleeping sleeping slumbering away that was the point of the game of course they don't make sense oh she's dead okay oh
oh, that was a dream interesting i
look down
and my
balls are gone that's just my nightmare okay thank you for playing the beta i
did it to everyone bassel good job bassel you did it you did a game bassel okay that was
Tried to try not to fall asleep
It was interesting i've definitely played better but i've also definitely played worse so and this is hourly version so who knows
maybe it will get better and more interesting that's it for me for now
watching another episode of the final
okay
See you guys in the next one this is me goodbye
To mike the edgar